bonjour à tous à suivre dans un instant
la suite et la fin de l'examen de la
réforme pénale au Sénat le texte a été
adopté hier par les sénateurs par
l'ensemble des forces de la gauche
tandis que l'UMP les centres on vote et
contre à l'exception notable du sénateur
UMP Jean-René lecer qui lui s'est
abstenu alors le texte qui a été adopté
profondément modifié par rapport à celui
de l'Assemblée nationale avec notamment
la contrainte pénale qui devient une
mesure autonome une peine autonome dans
la version du Sénat alors cette
contrainte pénale c'était l'une des
mesures phares du texte dans la version
de l'Assemblée nationale le juge pouvait
la prononcer à l'égard des coupables de
délit passible de 5 ans de prison et
moins c'est une peine de probation
c'est-à-dire en milieu ouvert en
extérieur assorti d'obligation pour les
condamner et dans la version du Sénat à
l'initiative du rapporteur socialiste
Jean-Pierre Michel cela devient la seule
peine que les juges puissent prononcer
pour un certain nombre de petits délits
autre modification de taille qui ont été
apportées au texte l'atténuation d'un
tiers de la peine pour les coupables qui
sont des malades mentaux le fait de
remettre en place la rétention de sûreté
ou encore la suppression des tribunaux
correctionnels pour mineurs c'est
d'ailleurs par ce moment que je vous
propose de commencer la séance ce matin
article 19 B
je suis saisie de trois amendements
identiques le premier c'est Monsieur le
cerf qui présente
par lequel les auteurs s'opposent à la
suppression des tribunaux correctionnels
pour mineurs ici oppose pour plusieurs
raisons la première raison c'est que la
loi qui les a mis en place est une loi
très récente et qu'il faudra peut-être
laisser du temps au temps pour pouvoir
juger de leur pertinence même si je
reconnais que les les premières les
premiers mois ou les premières années de
fonctionnement ne sont pas
particulièrement en faveur de leur
efficacité mais d'autre part il s'agit
effectivement d'un texte qui intéresse
les mineurs cette loi ne concerne pas
effectivement les mineurs donc je pense
que cette suppression a difficilement sa
place dans ce texte de loi et enfin nous
attendons tous à une réécriture de
l'ordonnance de 45 qui est aujourd'hui
devenue quasi lisible après les dizaines
de modifications qui ont été réalisées
et ils nous pensent que si évolution il
doit y avoir elle trouverait davantage
sa place dans cette réécriture de
l'ordonnance de 45 je vous remercie
Monsieur le Chef le 31 rectifié Monsieur
capocanella Merci merci madame la
Présidente après avoir débattu de la
rétention sûreté nous ouvrons à notre
dossier symbolique et important avec
l'hypothèse de suppression du tribunal
correctionnel pour mineur j'observe à la
ministre que nous nous rejoignons sans
doute pour des motifs différents mais en
tout cas la convergence d'amendement
montre sans doute que le sujet n'est pas
aujourd'hui mur et qu'il n'avait pas en
tout cas dans ce cadre
la question de la délinquance des
mineurs et tout de même tellement
prégnante qui me semble qu'on ne peut
pas la traiter par petit bout et que
sans doute faut-il examiner cette
question dans un cadre plus global
notamment dans le cadre d'une réflexion
sur
l'adaptation de l'ordonnance de 1945
c'est bien sûr un sujet particulièrement
sensible mais outre le fait que la
création de ces tribunaux correctionnels
pour mineurs et relativement récente
elle est difficilement tirer le bilan
aujourd'hui
je voudrais rappeler que le fait de
passer devant un tribunal correspond à
une charge symbolique et donne une
solennité qui peuvent apparaître
nécessaire à la compréhension par le
mineur de la réalité des actes qu'il a
pu commettre je vous remercie merci
Monsieur
le 96 présenté par Madame la Ministre
qui est identique oui madame la
Présidente Mesdames c'est notre
messieurs les sénateurs donc c'est votre
commission des Lois adoptée la
suppression des tribunaux correctionnels
pour mineurs
et
le débat vous avez suivi le débat à
l'Assemblée le débat avait été long vif
parce que des députés avaient souhaité
supprimer ces tribunaux correctionnel
pour mineur c'est tribunaux
correctionnel vous savez que c'est une
excroissance procédurale que c'est une
disposition qui a été introduite dans la
loi et qui donc
concerne qui qui s'inscrivait dans la
dynamique de rapprochement de la justice
des mineurs en justice des majeurs c'est
dans cette dynamique que ces
dispositions a été prise et puis dans
une période où la parole politique posée
sur cet acte là consistait à faire
apparaître la délinquance des mineurs
comme une délinquance en explosion une
délinquance de plus en plus grave de
plus en plus violente de plus en plus
massive or les statistiques ne disent
pas ça les statistiques ne disent pas ça
ça n'exclut pas qu'il y ait des cas et
d'ailleurs en général quand on prend un
exemple c'est toujours le même ça
n'exclut pas qui est et pas seulement un
cas sans doute il peut y en avoir
quelques-uns ça n'exclut pas qu'il y ait
des cas de mineurs qui se livrent des
délinquants graves répétitives
qui réitère qui récidive ça n'exclut pas
des cas mais la délinquance des mineurs
elle-même au contraire d'ailleurs au
contraire elle a stagné ou légèrement
baissé et la baisser en termes de
statistiques sur les 10 dernières années
le nombre de mineurs incarcéré le même
le la part de la délinquance des mineurs
dans l'ensemble de la délinquance ABC
j’entête une histoire de 18% je sais pas
si c'est ça
en tout cas elle a 18% c'est ça elle a
légèrement baissé donc voilà il y a eu
un discours sur la justice des mineurs
et c'est ce qu'on entend on a entendu en
pleurer que les jeunes d'aujourd'hui
sont pas comme les jeunes d'avant etc
bon il demeure que c'était ça le
contexte c'était pour machin c'est pas
pour porter un jugement de valeur quoi
que j'en pense mais c'était juste pour
tracer le contexte et donc dans cette
logique le ces tribunaux correctionnel
pour mineur ont été mises en place
moi et quoi qu'on en pense lorsqu'il
s'agit d'agir au nom de la puissance
publique
je ne me contente pas de mes convictions
personnelles il de mes propres élan je
veille à vérifier les choses donc une
des premières choses que j'ai faite a
été d'interroger les chefs de
juridiction sur le fonctionnement de ces
tribunaux correctionnels pour mineurs et
tous tous ont souhaité la suppression de
cet numéro en tout cas tous ceux qui se
exprimé leur volonté leur souhait de la
suppression de ces tribunaux
correctionnés pour mineurs certains pour
des raisons de conviction au sens où ils
considère que la justice des mineurs
doit rester une justice spécialisée que
c'est la tradition française avec la
création du juge pour enfants en 1912 et
l'ordonnance sur l'enfant délinquant de
1945 que c'est la tradition française
d'avoir une justice spécialisée pour les
mineurs donc certains par conviction
souhaitaient la suppression et d'autres
pour des raisons pratiques ont souhaité
la suppression en disant que cela
complique la gestion des juridictions
puisque c'est une juridiction qui se
réunit sous forme collégiale que ça
encombre que ça complique et qu'au
niveau des décisions le résultat à peu
près le même parce que il n'y a pas de
condamnation plus sévère ni plus massive
par les tribunaux correctionnels pour
mineurs que par les tribunaux pour
enfants
ça c'est la réalité c'est une réalité
que j'ai fait suivre régulièrement c'est
à dire que régulièrement j'ai fait voir
dans les juridictions si les
juridictions ont commencé à convoquer
les tribunaux correctionnels pour mineur
donc la position des praticiens des
professionnels demeurent pour celles qui
s'expriment et elle s'exprime sur des
sensibilités différentes parce que je
viens de dire que certains l'ont dit par
conviction d'autres juste pour des
raisons pratiques d'organisation de leur
juridiction c'est qu'il faut supprimer
cet essaim le gouvernement ne souhaite
pas que dans ce texte cette suppression
est lieu parce que le gouvernement
considère que c'est un texte sur les
délits donc autant que possible on
écarte aussi bien la disposition
relative aux longues peines que les
dispositions relatives aux mineurs pour
ma part je répète qu'il est souhaitable
pour le bon fonctionnement y compris
pour la bonne administration de la
justice qui laisse souhaitable que ces
tribunaux correctionnels pour mineurs
soit supprimés voilà donc je vous expose
le soin du gouvernement par cet
amendement que
ne soit pas supprimée dans ce texte mais
je ne me cache derrière aucun paravent
je vous dis très clairement que aussi
bien pour ce qui me concerne en tout cas
par conviction comme certains magistrats
qui pensent que la justice des mineurs
doit être doit rester une justice
spécialisée comme la plupart d'entre
vous je crois parce que l'ordonnance de
1945 était une production législative
d'un moment de grande unité nationale de
grande union nationale c'est le Conseil
National de la Résistance ce sont des
forces de la Résistance qui ont une
sensibilité de droite une sensibilité de
gauche sensibilité du centre qui se
retrouve toutes ces personnes là les
gouvernements qui suivent sont des
gouvernements qui sont animés je pense
par exemple notamment garde des Sceaux
de l'époque c'est-à-dire monsieur de
Menton qui était centrisme semble-t-il
en tout cas républicain je pense à
Monsieur tedjen ensuite garde des sceaux
donc c'est une production législative
d'une époque où il y avait une
convergence de la conception politique
sur la façon dont la société devait
traiter ces enfants y compris ses
enfants délinquants donc voilà je le dis
moi j'essaie de conviction là aussi et
puis en plus du point de vue pratique en
qualité de garde des sceaux pour la
bonne administration de la justice je
pense que conformément à la demande de
nombreux chefs de juridiction il est
souhaitable de supprimer ces tribunaux
correctionnels pour mineurs ils demeure
que voilà je vous présente un amendement
du Gouvernement qui vous demande de ne
pas maintenir dans ce texte
ça s'appelle la bipolarité
c'était une parenthèse de ne pas
maintenir dans ce texte là suppression
des tribunaux correctionnelle pour
mineur merci Madame la Ministre j'en
appelle à monsieur le rapporteur sur ces
trois amendements identiques
quelques mots la commission a rejeté
fort heureusement ces trois amendements
fort heureusement car pourquoi remettre
à plus tard ce qu'on peut faire
aujourd'hui dans le cadre d'un texte qui
est de nature correctionnelle vous
m'avez demandé vous m'avez demandé
madame lagard Desseaux à Monsieur le
Premier Ministre héros de me confier une
mission parlementaire sur la PJJ puis
largement sur les mineurs tous les
magistrats que j'ai rencontrés de la
tête aux pieds
son contre cette nouvelle juridique tous
et demandent l'abrogation le plus
rapidement possible car d'une part ça
désorganise des tribunaux et d'autre
part franchement le résultat des
condamnations etc enfin on voulait
qu'elle soit plus sévère paraît-il elles
ne sont pas pu sévères bon donc
faisons-le tout de suite aujourd'hui et
pour ma part y compris la commission
mixparitaire je pense c'est une un
amendement sur lequel il faut tenir bon
mes chers collègues sénateurs qui
avaient souvent montré la voix en
matière de liberté publique
merci monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
Président sueur
madame
la présidente et Madame la Ministre et
monsieur le rapporteur
moi je suis très attaché bien sûr comme
vous tous à des principes
tout à l'heure à propos de la rétention
de sûreté cette idée très forte selon
laquelle dans la République française on
est jugé condamnés pour des faits et non
pour des virtualités
et cet héritage de 45 dont vous avez
magnifiquement parlé madame la ministre
qui instaure une spécificité de la
justice des mineurs parce qu'on
considère que le mineur est un être en
devenir alors il y a des tas d'argucie
pour expliquer que cela serait suranné
que ça ne correspondrait plus à la
réalité il y a bien sûr des évolutions
dans la société
mais enfin qui va désespérer du cas d'un
jeune ni d'ailleurs d'un adulte mais a
fortiori d'un jeune la mineur
c'est pourquoi je n'ai pas grand chose à
ajouter à votre magnifique plaidoyer
madame la ministre vous avez dit comme
monsieur le rapporteur que tous les
magistrats que vous avez rencontrés je
pensais qu'il fallait supprimer ce
tribunal pour mineur
dans le rapport de notre collègue
Jean-Pierre Michel je lis
page 185 la création de ces tribunaux
relevés clairement d'une logique
tendance à rapprocher autant que
possible la justice des mineurs de celle
des majeurs cette logique ne reçoit pas
la probation de votre commission qui
considère que la spécificité de la
justice des mineurs doit perdurer
conformément au principe qui a guidé à
la rédaction de l'ordonnance du 2
février
1945 alors j'ai bien compris la force de
votre conviction madame la ministre et
aussi la force de votre explication en
vertu de laquelle il était préférable
que cela ne Figuera pas dans le présent
texte
ce n'est pas bipolaire ce sont deux
éléments c'est peut-être d'y allerctique
mais en tout cas madame la ministre j'ai
lu avec soin comme toujours l'objet de
votre amendement numéro 96
et je le lis le gouvernement n'est pas
hostile à la suppression du tribunal
correctionnel des mineurs
mais il estime que cette question doit
être examinée dans le cadre d'une
réforme d'ensemble de l'ordonnance de
1945 relative à l'enfance délinquante
cela est bien dit cela est bien écrit
madame la ministre et je me permets ici
simplement
d'appeler de mes vœux on peut
mais non mais madame madame la ministre
je pense écouter il y a beaucoup de
sujets à l'ordre du jour du Parlement et
je ne suis très calme il y a beaucoup de
sujets à l'ordre du jour le matin le
midi le soir bien il y a des procédures
à n'ont plus finir
cet après-midi nous en parlions avec
Philippe Kaltenbach à l'instant cet
après-midi nous avons assisté à la mise
en oeuvre d'une procédure et nous
respectons les procédures bon mais
seulement moi je dis que dans l'emploi
du temps il y a des priorités et moi je
me permets de dire que je considère que
ce serait une priorité pour les
prochains mois pour l'examen au
Parlement de ce que vous appelez de vos
vœux c'est-à-dire une réforme d'ensemble
de l'ordonnance de 1945 parce que je
crois que la question des mineurs de la
délinquance chez les mineurs
et des mineurs dans notre société madame
la ministre est une vraie question dont
moi je considère qu'on doit trouver le
temps dans les prochains mois de traiter
de cette question elle est au moins
aussi nécessaire que beaucoup d'autres
voilà merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur capocanella
merci madame la Présidente je crois
qu'il ne faut évidemment pas stigmatiser
les mineurs et nous devons aborder cette
question avec sérénité je remercie
madame Lagarde des sceaux des éléments
d'analyse qu'elle a bien voulu nous
communiquer
et de la réflexion d'ensemble qu'elle a
essayé de poser avec nous j'entends les
arguments de fond et les arguments
pratiquent que vous évoquez madame la
ministre pour dire que à un terme
relativement bref vous estimez qu'il
faut pratiquer cette suppression pour la
bonne administration de la justice ce
débat là n'est pas tabous on peut
l'ouvrir et on peut l'ouvrir dans le
cadre global que vous avez évoqué
pour autant sur les statistiques que
vous avez évoquées vous vous permettrez
de
en tout cas d'être dubitatif parce qu'il
est des territoires il est des parties
de notre vieille France où
la question de la justice des mineurs se
pose avec une acuité particulière et où
il y a un centre de phénomènes qui a
malgré tout ont une réalité statistique
je pense cette question de traiter dans
un cadre global et avec sérénité comme
vous le disiez je crée un cadeau ici
cette disposition de suppression est un
double effet négatif je m'explique un
elle ne prend pas en compte la globalité
du sujet et deuxièmement si nous
supprimons à ce stade dans ce texte de
loi les tribus de nos corrections
mineurs cette mesure-là sera
immécablement additionnée par un certain
nombre de contrevenants et ça sera très
clair pour eux ils considèreront que
pour certains délits la prison n'existe
plus premier point et il considèreront
qu'en plus on a supprimé le tribunal
correctionnel pour les mineurs je pense
que ce sont deux signaux qu'il faut pas
adresser en même temps et qu'il faut
détacher les deux questions attention au
signal qu'on donnera pour un certain
nombre de réitérents pour lesquels on a
un travail de prévention à faire
pour un travail de lutte contre la
récidive et si on additionne ces deux
mesures je crée au contraire l'effet
négatif merci
si chers collègues Monsieur Mohamed
Salah
oui madame la Présidente la question est
importante
la suppression des tribunaux
correctionnels pour mineurs ne veut pas
dire impunité pour les mineurs
il faut le préciser cela va de soi mais
il faut le préciser
il y a des cas où il y a des sujets
qu'on peut remettre à demain mais
celui-ci symboliquement par son
importance parce que il touche à la
spécialisation
de notre justice des mineurs il faut le
régler tout de suite
c'est pour cela que je vous demande
contenu de l'importance du sujet par
rapport à la place spécifique de la
justice de nos mineurs dans notre droit
répressif et bien faisons-le
immédiatement parce que c'est un sujet
qui ne peut pas attendre symboliquement
présidente pour dire simplement que je
rejoins totalement l'argumentation qui
était développée par mon collègue
kapokanellas je j'ajouterai que les
dispositions essentielles de
l'ordonnance de 45 ont été
constitutionnalisés qu'il s'agisse
effectivement de la primauté de
l'éducatif sur la sanction qu'il
s'agisse également de la diminution de
l'importance des peines et à cette
constitutionnalisation aujourd'hui
protège à ces dispositions essentielles
je ferai également observer que la loi
lorsqu'elle a été à la loi qui portait
notamment c'était pas sa seule la seule
disposition qui portait notamment
création des tribunaux correctionnels
pour mineur a été soumise au Conseil
constitutionnel que le Conseil
constitutionnel en a effectivement
reconnu la constitutionnalité et je
terminerai en disant que il me
paraîtrait être réellement une décision
à la sauvette que de décider dans la fin
effectivement d'un débat sur ce texte
important à 10 par de des mois dans
l'hémicycle de supprimer cette
disposition et de supprimer les
tribunaux correctionnels pour mineurs de
cette manière là
je vous remercie monsieur le cerf madame
kukermann
oui madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues on peut regretter le nombre
que nous sommes à la fin de cette
discussion c'est un discussion que nous
avons eu en commission et je crois en
tout cas pour un certain nombre de
groupes présents ici nous nous étions
fortement opposés à leur création il y a
quelques années sous les précédents
gouvernement donc
ce débat se poursuit et s'inscrit en
quelque sorte dans la continuité
bien évidemment
nous aurions toutes et tous j'ai même
envie de dire commencer par vous même la
garde des sceaux souhaité avoir un texte
sur la justice des mineurs qui puisse
trouver le temps dans ce calendrier
parlementaire assez contraint finalement
pour remettre à plat cette ordonnance de
45 en de 45 pardon en garder bien
évidemment sa substantifique moelle et
la mettre au diapason de ce 21e siècle
en tout cas cela n'est n'est pas le cas
n'est pas possible en l'état et pourtant
avec ce texte qui vise à individualiser
mieux les peines à prendre en
considération la spécificité finalement
de de chacune et de chacun nous pensons
que introduire la suppression du
tribunal correctionnel pour mineur est
un acte fort tout d'abord parce que il
s'inscrit aussi dans la volonté d'une
autre justice plus largement et puis il
s'inscrit dans cette démarche un petit
peu plus large on élargissant bien
évidemment le le chant du texte de de
bien d'éviter les généralisations
je crois que c'est plus qu'un symbole
un acte fort de supprimer ce tribunal
correctionnel parce que vous l'avez
rappelé il a finalement pas été mis en
place pour répondre à un problème mais
il a été mis en place parce que il
fallait apporter des mesures qui
satisfont l'opinion publique dans
l'immédiateté et qui ne résout pas
forcément les mots de la société sur le
long terme donc pour toutes ces raisons
bien évidemment nous ne voterons pas ces
amendements qui visent à supprimer la
suppression du tribunal correctionnel
pour mineur merci madame cucarmann
monsieur Kaltenbach
oui il est certain que tous nous
aimerions débat d'une grande loi sur la
justice des mineurs mais nous avons
l'opportunité aujourd'hui de supprimer
ces tribunaux correctionnels pour
mineurs qui à l'usage ne servent à rien
et au bout d'un moment il faut quand
même aussi regarder l'efficacité des
dispositifs qui sont votés par le
Parlement depuis deux ans nous le
constatons c'est inefficace les
professionnels le disent alors pourquoi
conserver ces tribunaux correctionnels
pour mineurs qui en plus sont en
contradiction avec l'ordonnance de 1945
parce que nous aurions peur du qu'en
dira-t-on de l'opinion publique de
certains qui pourraient l'exploiter en
disant regardez non ça suffit nous
sommes ici pour légiférer nous avons des
tribunal pour une heure qui ne servent à
rien qui sont inutiles les
professionnels nous demandent de les
supprimer c'était en plus un engagement
de la campagne de François Hollande
voilà il faut il faut aussi il faut il
faut dire clairement que ça a été validé
par les électeurs
et puis je crois qu'il faut assumer si
nous sommes tous d'accord pour dire que
ces tribunaux ne servent à rien ne sont
pas utiles que les professionnels en
dénoncent l'utilité et bien nous pouvons
ensemble porter ce débat et convaincre
l'opinion qu'en effet c'est tribunaux de
servent à rien et qu'il est utile de les
supprimer et moi je soutiens
complètement la position du rapporteur
sur ce point et je crois avec l'ensemble
des sénateurs socialistes merci Monsieur
cathlon bac monsieur de treilles
merci de la Présidente je voudrais dire
à nos collègues de la majorité que
lorsqu'ils étaient dans l'opposition il
y a quelques années et reprochait
beaucoup notamment dans le domaine pénal
qu'il y ait des dispositions qui
viennent à la suite d'un fait divers etc
et que l'on modifie au coup par coup
sans vision d'ensemble les dispositifs
mis en place et bien là je pense que et
ça a été dit beaucoup de monde le
reconnaît là
sur le sur la justice pour les mineurs
il y a eu effectivement un certain
nombre de modifications est-ce qu'il
faut ces modifications elles ont
peut-être été faites au coup par coup
mais ce qu'il faut des tricoter au coup
par coup moi je pense qu'il faudrait
avoir une vision globale si on veut et
il faut sans doute repenser la justice
des mineurs ça date pour l'essentiel
effectivement de la fin de la guerre
évidemment la situation a changé je
préférerais qu'on ait une vision
d'ensemble qu'on repose la problématique
dans son ensemble dans les conditions
d'aujourd'hui avec ce qu'est aujourd'hui
la délinquance des mineurs plutôt que de
détricoter au coup par coup ce qui a été
tricoté et là aussi au coup par coup
si chers collègues la parole est à
Madame classe
pour avoir fait pas mal de tricots dans
ma jeunesse et quand j'en avais le temps
je vais reprendre l'image de notre
collègue de traîne pour dire que malgré
tout quand il y a deux trois fausses
mailles d'un seul coup d'un seul vaut
mieux tout retirer le rang d'un seul
coup d'un seul plutôt que d'essayer de
récupérer mais par mail donc je pense
effectivement que les tribunaux
correctionnels pour mineurs étaient une
mauvaise idée c'était des très mauvaises
mailles dans un tricot on a
l'opportunité par un texte qui n'est pas
qu'une se situe pas comme un cavalier
législatif de supprimer ces tribunaux
correctionnel pour mineurs et puis ne
dramatisons quand même rien les mineurs
avant l'existence de ces tribunaux
correctionnels pour mineurs étaient
repéré quand ils étaient délinquants
étaient sanctionnés par les instances
nécessaires et adaptés au fait qu'il
s'était mineur le seront encore demain
quand bien même il n'y aurait plus de
tribunaux correctionnel pour mineurs
donc c'est pas parce qu'on les fait
disparaître qu'on fait disparaître tout
l'appareil juridique destiné à lutter
contre la délinquance des mineurs c'est
un outil qui n'était que très peut
utiliser mal utilisé qui encombre les
tribunaux tous les professionnels
veulent qu'on le supprime alors ayant le
courage de la vérité et pas de se cacher
derrière des mots en disant oh là là
s'il y a plus les tribunaux corrections
il faut tout reprendre oui il faut tout
reprendre ça n'empêche pas de défaire là
c'est de rangs qui sont tricotés
complètement à l'envers donc oui il faut
les supprimer aujourd'hui et c'est pas
parce qu'on fait aujourd'hui que les
mineurs ne seront plus sanctionnés quand
ils seront des mineurs délinquants
je vous remercie madame Claisse
très bien il n'y a plus de demandes de
parole sur cet amendements je vais donc
passer au vote
à madame la ministre
non non non madame la ministre
d'abord j'ai été interpellé par le
président de la commission des lois et
par préséance je lui donne réponse à
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois nous travaillons sur la
l'ordonnance de 1945 donc je rappelle
qu'elle a été modifiée 37 fois et du
coup elle est elle contient de
nombreuses incohérences et tous les
praticiens parce que ça fait plus de 8
mois que nous y travaillons nous avons
reçu les organisations professionnelles
les organisations syndicales les
associations qui interviennent tous nous
disent il faut y mettre de la cohérence
parce que c'était lisible on ne sait
plus quoi faire entre les sanctions
éducatives des mesures éducatives il
faut simplifier les procédures tous nous
disent qu'il faut remettre de la
cohérence dans leur donnant de 1945 donc
nous y travaillons et les choses sont
pratiquement abouties maintenant
maintenant voilà vous savez bien que
c'est pas moi qui peut prendre là à ce
micro un engagement de calendrier sur
l'inscription de ce texte je souhaite
profond parce que ça c'est plus juste
d'une part et ce sera plus efficace
puisque les professionnels eux-mêmes le
souhaitent j'en profite simplement pour
donner quelques chiffres parce que je
crois qu'il est nécessaire d'éclairer la
représentation nationale sur les
réalités il y a le ressenti il a
perception il y a l'effet que peut faire
une émission de télévision et puis à la
réalité la réalité sur la délinquance
des mineurs c'est que comme je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure elle a baissé dans
l'ensemble de la délinquance elle est à
18% elle était à 20 ou 21% il y a
quelques années ensuite elle a je vais
vous donner quelques autres chiffres
parce qu'on entend beaucoup de choses
des mineurs sont de plus en plus jeunes
de plus en plus violents
ils pratiquent ils exercent des
e-commettes des actes de plus en plus
scandaleux et ils sont de moins en moins
punis
alors des chiffres simplement que je
tiendrai plus en détail à votre
disposition si vous le souhaitez la
délinquance des mineurs
qui évidemment
personne n'a la mineur mais nous la
mesurons de 2004 à 2012 il représentait
je viens de vous le dire
de 20 à 18% ils sont passés à 18
personnes pour cent des personnes
interpellées
le nombre de mineurs mis en cause par la
police nationale a diminué de 12,6%
entre juillet 2011 et juin 2013 sont les
chiffres de la police nationale pour les
mineurs délinquants le premier contact
avec la justice est fortement dissuasif
c'est-à-dire que 65 % des mineurs ne
récidive pas
65 % des mineurs qui ont eu un premier
contact avec la justice on est revoit
pas l'étude a été faite sur six ans sur
six années on les revoit pas et on sait
bien que le processus c'est que plus
l'âge avance est moins plus les gens
sortent de la délinquance d'une façon
générale c'est une tendance lourde
ensuite est-ce qu'ils sont de plus en
plus violents il y a des homicides
volontaires commis par
volontaires commis par des mineurs
le taux est de 4 à 7% de l'effectif
total des condamnés pour homicide
sur l'ensemble des faits susceptibles
d'être qualifier de criminels la part
des mineurs est inférieure à 1%
. les atteintes volontaires à
l'intégrité physique
quand on baisse
et son passé en 2010 à 2013 de moins 18%
de même que en baissé de 18% pardon de
même que les vols avec violence ont
baissé de moins
13,9 %. j'ai bientôt fini monsieur le
rapporteur les mineurs de l'inquin dont
on dit qu'ils sont de plus en plus
jeunes
les moindres les moins de 13 ans ne
représentent que 4% des mineurs qui sont
auteurs de délits ce sont les chiffres
de 2012
les juridictions pour mineurs dont on
dit qu'elles sont laxistes et seraient
justifiées justement c'est la création
de ces tribunaux correctionnels pour
mineurs
le taux de réponse pénale pour les
mineurs est de
93,5% alors qu'il n'est il est de 89%
pour les adultes j'allais dire il n'est
que 89% c'est un taux élevé de réponse
pénale pour les adultes il est de 89 %
pour les mineurs et de 93,5 %. enfin
concernant les tribunaux pour enfants
dont j'ai dit tout à l'heure qu'ils
étaient de même sévérité sinon un peu
plus même parfois que les tribunaux
correctionnels pour mineurs qui ont été
créés pour que les jugements soient plus
sévères les tribunaux pour enfants se
montrent très sévères puisque 61% des
peines prononcées en 2012 qu'on portait
de l'emprisonnement
ferme ou avec sursis alors qu'en 2010
c'était 52% en 2011 53%. donc les
tribunaux pour enfants sont sévères et
même plus sévères en moyenne que les
tribunaux correctionnels pour mineurs
donc voilà ce sont des chiffres que je
devais porter à votre connaissance ce
qui ne change ni la position officielle
que je vous ai communiquée du
gouvernement ni bien sûr
ni bien sûr autre chose
merci madame la ministre
je veux m'assurer qu'il n'y a plus de
demandes de parole je vais donc mettre
au voile les trois amendements
identiques dont celui du gouvernement
qui a reçu un avis défavorable de la
commission qui est pour voter qui veut
voter ses amendements
merci qui est contre
merci absention c'est un amendements ne
sont pas adoptés nous arrivons monsieur
le président
bien simplement à préciser au Sénat que
je demanderai à la commission des lois
de moment dater pour intervenir auprès
du Premier ministre de manière à ce que
un débat sur la question de la justice
des mineurs puisse être inscrit lors des
prochains mois
merci monsieur le président
je vais donc appeler la maman 114
Monsieur Jean-Pierre Michel
je vous remercie madame la ministre
merci je voulais vous voir normalement
de la commission de coordination à vie
favorable du gouvernement qui est pour
merci contre abstention l'amendement est
adopté nous arrivons à un vote sur
l'article 19b qui est pour voter
l'article dans votre sur l'article mes
collègues mes chers collègues merci qui
est contre
abstention l'article est adopté
après l'article 19b un amendement 74
madame Benbassa
c'est un moment vise à simplifier la
procédure pénale pour les délits en
matière de liberté de la presse il
s'agit sans porter bien évidemment
atteinte au droit de la défense de
permettre la mise en examen par simple
aide dans un cadre extrêmement
circonscrit en l'état du droit dans le
cas des infractions prévues par la loi
du 29 juillet
1991 le juge est tenu de convoquer
physiquement les personnes poursuivies
pour simplement vérifier leur identité
sans pouvoir juger au fond cela entraîne
une perte de temps considérable tant
pour les juges d'instruction que pour
les justiciables comme les directeurs de
publication contraint de faire des
kilomètres pour simplement décliner leur
identité le groupe écologiste souhaite
donc supprimer cette procédure inutile
et lourde via l'introduction de
l'article
116-2 au code de procédure pénale avec
mon collègue André gatola nous savons
que cette mesure d'allègement la
procédure pénale à le soutien des
éditeurs de presse comme de nombreux
magistrats elle permettra en effet de
rationaliser le temps du juge et de la
presse alors que la qualité du
traitement des justiciables dépend
largement de la charge de travail des
magistrats je tiens à signaler que c'est
un manque c'est pour attirer l'attention
de madame la ministre sur cette question
et c'est pour ça que qu'il est enfin
qu'il ressent plutôt à un cavalier mais
j'avais pas d'autres moyens pour attirer
son attention merci merci Madame Massa
monsieur rapporteur
n'a pas sa place dans ce texte donc je
pense qu'elle sera prête à le retirer
lorsque madame la garde des sceaux lui
aura succinctement répondu je vous
remercie madame la ministre
succinctement il y a de plus en plus
aimable
simplement je comprenais l'attention
madame la sénatrice mais très
sincèrement il n'y a pas de lien direct
entre votre amendement enfin la
disposition que vous proposez et le
texte dont nous débattons donc je vous
propose en retrait merci merci madame la
ministre
vous le retirez madame Benbassa merci
après l'article 19b un amendement 103
qui n'est pas défendu il tombe
puis un moment sans directifié bis qui
n'est pas défendu non plus il tombe à
moins que vous les repreniez monsieur
rapporteur non vous n'avez pas
l'intention voilà merci merci article je
vous ai vu prêt à bondir article 19
l'amendement 115 voilà vous le présentez
qui a été qui présenté par la commission
des lois dit qu'il convient de prévoir à
l'article 735 du code de procédure
pénale qui permet à un détenu dans le
circuit a été automatiquement révoqué de
demander après sa condamnation être
dispensé être révocation et que 58 et
s'appliquait dans la rédaction actuelle
pour prévoir la situation des personnes
dans le sursis a été révoqué de plein
droit par une condamnation prononcée
antérieurement à l'entrée en vigueur de
la loi c'est un peu technique mais je
crois que la fête de bon sens merci
monsieur le rapporteur la vie de madame
la ministre sur l'amendement de la
commission
c'est un avis défavorable madame
Président je vous remercie bien s'il y a
pas de demande de parole sur cet
amendement je le mets aux voix un
amendement présenté par la commission
qui a reçu la vie défavorable du
gouvernement
pardon
pardonnez-moi
de l'amendement madame la Présidente
donc c'est un avis favorable c'est le
tien donc ça a été tellement
merci
bien je mets aux voix l'amendement de la
commission des lois la vie favorable du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui est pour merci contre abstention
l'amendement est adopté j'ai demandé à
votre sur l'article 19 qui est pour
voter l'article merci qui est contre
abstention l'article est adopté après
l'article 19b un amendement 86 madame
picardman oui madame la présidente
Madame la miss mes chers collègues à
travers cet amendement qui reprend pour
la plupart les termes de notre
proposition de loi sur le fichage
génétique nous souhaitons tout d'abord
permettre
à ce que ce fichage génétique puisse
être encadré notamment en mettant en
place une procédure qui permettrait le
retrait des données enregistrées puisque
actuellement la durée d'enregistrement
des informations est exorbitante elle
peut aller jusqu'à 40 ans et on peut
regretter que l'amnistie et la
réhabilitation soit dépourvue de tout
est fait quand on maintient des données
dans ce fichier nous proposons également
à travers cet amendement qu'un certain
nombre de personnes puissent être
extraite ne soit pas obligé pardon de
d'entrer dans dans ce fichier les
mineurs les personnes poursuivent pour
des faits commis à l'occasion d'activité
syndicale et revendicative les simples
les simples suspects pardon et que donc
seul les personnes qui seraient
réellement condamnés puissent être
effectivement
intégré à ce fichier alors que l'on a
parlé depuis le début de réinsertion de
droit à l'oubli il nous semble
qu'effectivement un certain nombre de
mesures doivent être prises en compte et
puis aussi qu'un certain nombre de
mesures doivent être pris en compte je
pense notamment aux militants syndicaux
pour ne pas
aggraver les peines que parfois
ils peuvent encourir puisque nous
l'avons vu notamment à travers l'affaire
des cinq de Roanne que le refus d'un
prélèvement peut amener à une
condamnation supplémentaire donc tel
objet de cette amendement j'ai essayé de
synthétiser j'espère être resté clair
dans mes propos et vous avoir convaincu
madame la ministre puisque je n'ai pas
été désagréable à votre égard depuis le
début du débat donc je ne doute pas que
de
voilà mais je ce n'est pas dans Nature
donc j'attends bien évidemment le sort
que vous allez réserver à notre
amendement je vous remercie chers
collègues la vie de la Commission
bien sûr la Commission a bien compris le
but de votre amendement mais
vous remplacez la durée de 40 ans qui
est prévu par décret à une notion de
durée de conservation nécessaire on sait
très bien que ce genre de phrase très
apprécié peut donner lieu à toutes les
interprétations et même à une durée qui
pourrait être supérieure à 40 ans donc
nous avons dit que nous pensons que
c'est un vrai vrai question qu'il faut
peut-être une réflexion plus aboutie
pour concilier à la fois l'efficacité et
le droit à l'oubli donc on vous avait
demandé un retrait sinon la vie serait
défavorable malheureusement merci
monsieur le rapporteur madame la
ministre
oui madame la présidente madame la
sénatrice qui amène et je sais que votre
groupe est à vos côtés sur
pour cet amendement parce que je dois
saluer votre constance
votre constance dans l'action et
l'initiative et votre constance aussi
dans l'argumentaire que vous présentez
nous avons eu un échange vous souvenez à
l'occasion j'allais presque dire à la
faveur d'une proposition de loi qui a
connu après une trajectoire un peu un
peu chaotique
caoteuse simplement voilà
alors juste la difficulté là je vous
avais dit alors c'était à l'occasion
d'un autre texte un débat notamment sur
la conservation des scellés j'avais eu
l'occasion de vous dire que le
gouvernement travaillait nous avions
commencé un travail avec le ministère
d'intérieur pour modifier les conditions
d'inscription les conditions
d'effacement et la durée de conservation
des informations donc nous avons deux
décrets qui sont pratiquement finalisés
dans la publication je me tourne vous
avez les dates en tête enfin bon c'est
imminent nous avons de décret alors il
concerne les conditions les conditions
d'effacement parce que vous savez que
nous avons eu des observations c'est du
Conseil constitutionnel des observations
une décision
sur les conditions d'effacement de ces
données sur et nous travaillons
également sur la limitation de durée des
informations concernant les mineurs il y
a un sujet sur le Fnac mais aussi sur le
Tage par exemple et je crois qu'il y a
lieu de travailler sur les infractions
de travailler de façon
peut-être plus collectif plus
coordonnées entre nous
sur le fond donc je vous propose
j'entends
et j'entends au double sens du terme
vous le savez parfaitement mais je vous
propose que nous puissions continuer à
travailler et je suggère donc un retrait
de cet amendement
merci Madame la Ministre madame
cutermann vous êtes sollicité deux fois
par le retrait j'entends ce que vous
dites madame la gardeesseau sachez
effectivement que vous l'avez dit mais
l'ensemble de notre groupe est
disponible à travailler je note quand
même que la précision peut-être de
certains passages notre argument elle
est tout autant que la publication
imminente qui qui peut parfois non voilà
non non mais je
d'accord on sait le contre voilà bon on
doit avoir une complémentarité alors
donc voilà non mais pas de souci sur
cette question en tout cas sachez que
nous sommes là j'ai envie de dire que
nous ne lâcherons rien sur cette
question comme sur d'autres que bien
évidemment à travers ce débat je ne
doute pas que cela fera résonance et
j'en invite à l'ensemble des députés
qui de gauche en tout cas qui ont été
élus comme étant une majorité de députés
de gauche a sorti de du renvoi en
commission ce texte sur l'amnistie pour
les syndicalistes qui prenaient en
compte une partie de cette question sur
le fichage j'invite y compris le
gouvernement a convaincre la majorité
des députés comme il sait le faire sur
de nombreux textes quand un certain
nombre de députés de sa majorité semble
faire un petit peu de rébellion j'invite
le gouvernement vraiment à convaincre
cette majorité à le faire et convaincu
que tout cela se fera en toute
intelligence nous retirons notre
amendement mais beaucoup plus convaincu
madame la garde des sceaux que nous
travaillerons notre groupe et vos
services sur ces questions là je vous
remercie
donc
merci Madame cukermann nous arrivons à
l'article 20 deux amendements en
discussion communes le 122 madame la
ministre vous voulez bien le présenter
oui ça j'ai en fait non c'est Monsieur
Michel alors je viens
116 122
d'accord oui mais c'est pas moi qui
défend monsieur
faire son travail tout seul c'est
d'abord
merci madame la Présidente donc il
s'agit de mesures transitoires
il s'agit donc de disposition
transitoire concernant l'application
de certaines mesures contenues dans ce
texte de loi
pour des raisons d'efficacité il y a la
loi sera promulguée juste avant l'été
donc il y a des dispositions qui
pourront pas être appliquées parce que
nos juridictions
il faut pas qu'elles se mettent en faute
vis-à-vis du législateur donc nous
demandons un différé d'un mois dans
certains cas de trois mois dans d'autres
de six mois donc en fait ce sont des
dispositions pratiques pour assurer une
meilleure des meilleures conditions
d'efficacité des dispositions contenues
dans ce texte de loi merci madame la
ministre monsieur Michel
concerne également la mise à
l'application et ce suggère au
gouvernement de
retirer son amendement au profit du mien
car dans la mesure où le Sénat a adopté
l'article 8 ter
qui fait de la contrainte pénale une
peine autonome je pense qu'il faut dire
quelle est l'application immédiate
car sinon il aurait des hiatus qui ne
serait pas acceptable alors on verra
plus tard après CMP merci monsieur le
rapporteur madame la ministre
vous me demandez un avis sur
l'abonnement du rapporteur monsieur non
monsieur le rapporteur vous a suggéré de
vous rallier à son amendement
rien que ça
non mais oui
bon objectivement
la loi il y aura le temps nécessaire
pour les décrets d'application on
pourrait jouer sur ça moi je ne joue
jamais là-dessus vous avez vu sur la loi
pénitentiaire par exemple il manquait
des décrets d'application nous avons
travaillé d'arrache-pied aujourd'hui
tous les décrets d'application étaient
publiés donc moi j'estime que la
crédibilité du travail législative donc
du travail que vous fournissez sa
crédibilité c'est que les règles que
vous énoncez soient applicables pour
qu'elle soit applicable parfois il faut
des décrets d'application s'il exécutif
s'amuse à jouer le temps sur les décrets
d'application il décrédibilise la loi le
travail des législateurs
donc je pourrais faire ça là mais je
m'interdis de le faire les dégâts
d'applications pourraient traînés et à
ce moment-là c'est ce délai de
mesures dérogatoires enfin ce délai
dérogatoire que je vous demande je me
l'offrirai moi-même
je demande que ce soit vous qui nous
l'accordiez que ce soit clairement
est-ce que dans la loi voilà le sens de
la démarche par ailleurs il y a les
raisons pratiques
nos conseils d'insertion et de probation
que nous avons recruté que nous mettons
en formation les groupes de travail
l'élaboration des outils voilà demander
des délais raisonnables ce sont des
délais raisonnables moi trois mois six
mois de délai raisonnable bon donc
monsieur s'y étant moi j'entendrai que
vous ayez l'impatience d'une application
immédiate mais voilà le gouvernement
vous demande ça donc pour ces raisons
pour ces raisons je ne me rallie pas
merci beaucoup madame la ministre donc
je vais oui oui je suis embêté parce
qu'il n'y a pas d'avis sur le moment
sans cesse de Monsieur Michel parce que
c'est en discussion commune donc que je
peux comprendre ne me ralliant pas je
voilà la vie défavorable je préfère vous
l'entendre dire je vous remercie alors
la maman 122
Monsieur Michel Le maman
du gouvernement vous aviez demandé le
bâtiment
j'y suis hostile bien entendu
gouvernement n'est pas applicable en
l'état alors car alors si on veut plus
d'explications je vais en donner mais il
va y avoir un frisson dans l'hémicycle
oui le Sénat a adopté la contrainte
pénale comme peine autonome pour toute
une série de délits
si comme c'est une peine plus douce
si elle n'est pas applicable
immédiatement
signifie que toutes les personnes qu'on
donne à une peine de prison avec ou sans
sursis pour ces délits là doivent être
immédiatement libérées en prison
puisque cette peine n'existe plus donc
il faut adopter dire que la contrainte
pénale s'applique immédiatement pour
qu'elle se substitue automatiquement
pour ces délits là à ces peines voilà
c'est tout c'est la raison pour laquelle
je préfère ma mise en application que
celle du gouvernement merci mais j'ai
préféré vous l'entendre dire monsieur le
rapporteur donc voilà c'est très clair
je vais mettre en voix donc la maman 122
présenté par le gouvernement qui a reçu
un avis défavorable de la commission je
le mets aux voix qui est pour
qui est contre
merci abstention
l'amendement présenté par le
gouvernement n'est pas adopté
je mets aux voix l'amendement 116 de
Monsieur Jean-Pierre Michel j'ai reçu
lui un avis défavorable du gouvernement
qui est pour
merci qui est contre
abstention l'amendement est adopté
nous arrivons en vote sur l'article 20
qui vote l'article 20 qui est pour merci
qui est contre abstention l'article 20
est adopté nous arrivons à l'article 21
un amendement 117 présenté par Monsieur
Michel
coordination pour une meilleure
application du texte dans les
départements et territoires d'outre-mer
je vous remercie
je vais demander la vie de madame la
ministre sur cet amendement
c'est le dernier
Madame le Ministre j'ai besoin de votre
avis sur la maman 117 de Monsieur
Jean-Pierre Michel c'est les amendements
classiques sur
sur l'autre mère quels sont applicables
autour de bien entendu oui pardon enfin
oui c'est un avis favorable
je le mets au bois avec un avis
favorable du gouvernement qui est pour
merci contre abstention l'amendement est
adopté
l'article est ainsi rédigé
je mets au voile article 22 qui est pour
c'est le dernier je vous remercie qui
est contre abstention l'article est
adopté je m'apprête à mettre au voile
l'ensemble du projet de loi y a-t-il des
demandes d'explication de vote monsieur
des trains
merci madame la présidente madame la
garde des sceaux monsieur le rapporteur
mes chers collègues
lors de la discussion générale nous
avions clairement affiché notre volonté
de rentrer pleinement dans le débat sur
cette réforme sans adopter une posture
d'opposition systématique nous avons
rappelé à plusieurs reprises que nous
n'étions pas opposés à la version
initiale de la contrainte pénale telle
que proposait par le texte du
Gouvernement notre position ouverte
avait cependant ses limites puisque nous
avions également affiché clairement
notre position à plusieurs des
modifications introduites par notre
rapporteur dont nous saluons une fois de
plus la qualité du travail et pourtant
nous ne pouvons souscrire à la posture
selon laquelle la justice devrait être
au service d'une idéologie la justice
est au service de nos concitoyens et
c'est en fonction de leurs besoins et
des besoins de la société que doit être
construit notre système pénal c'est nous
semble-t-il une règle de bon sens nous
entendons les arguments de ceux et
celles qui nous rappellent que l'une des
vocations du Sénat et la protection des
droits fondamentaux est donc à ce titre
de la nécessité des peines toujours
est-il que la sécurité et la justice
sont également des droits fondamentaux
et qu'il est également de notre devoir
de les défendre l'équilibre du texte sur
lequel nous nous apprêtons à voter n'est
donc pas satisfaisant l'idéologie n'est
pas l'ingrédient des bonnes lois et le
présentait
d'une certaine manière une illustration
malgré le soutien du gouvernement à
notre amendement de suppression
l'article 8 ter article essentiel a été
maintenu pour une série de délits le
Sénat donc voté la suppression de la
peine de référence actuellement en
vigueur l'emprisonnement pour imposer la
contrainte pénale portant ainsi atteinte
à la libre appréciation du juge alors
que ce texte est censé la renforcer
le système proposé fait donc disparaître
la peine de prison pour plusieurs délits
y compris en cas de récidive pour
reprendre les mots de Madame Lagarde des
sceaux cette modification procède une
confusion sur l'objectif et le contenu
de la peine de contraintes pénale
complexifie la répression et aboutit
finalement à un affaiblissement la
répression nous étions également
fermement opposés à la suppression de la
rétention de sûreté nos arguments
heureusement étaient entendus avec
l'adoption des amendements de
suppression de l'article 18 quater A ce
régime pose pour l'heure des difficultés
de mise en oeuvre cependant nous savons
bien que certains individus extrêmement
dangereux ne sauraient être remis en
liberté sans que la puissance publique
assure le minimum de sûreté garantie à
terme par cette disposition peut-être
fera-t-il peaufiner son régime dans les
années qui viennent le débat reste donc
ouvert sur ce sujet
la présente loi avait pour objet de
faire un trait sur les dispositifs
introduits dans notre droit pénal par
les précédents gouvernements nous avons
déjà pu nous exprimer sur le sujet en
discussion générale mais je rappelle une
fois de plus que les outils
d'individualisation des peines existent
déjà et que les peines plancher sont peu
utilisés mais ont un important effet
dissuatif globalement à l'issue des
débats nous en restons peu au proue à la
rédaction du texte proposé par notre
commission des lois à l'initiative de
notre rapporteur je me garderai bien
dans déduire une quelconque conclusion
quant à l'utilité de nos débats
toutefois je ne peux que regretter que
nous aboutissions un texte qui envoie
sur plusieurs points un signal de
l'axisme à nos concitoyens l'équilibre
issu des travaux de l'Assemblée
nationale étaient manifestement plus en
phase avec les positions défendues par
les sénateurs du groupe
udi Union centriste aussi madame la
présidente Madame Lagarde des sceaux mes
chers collègues comme vous l'aurez sans
doute d'ores et déjà compris le groupe
udi UC votre rencontre le présent projet
de loi je vous remercie je vous remercie
chers collègues la parole est à Madame
taska
merci madame la Présidente alors nous
arrivons au terme de l'examen de ce
projet de loi dans notre assemblée un
examen qui n'a pas été paisible mais qui
aurait pu penser que sur un tel sujet
les débats puissent être complètement
paisible néanmoins avec les collègues de
du groupe socialiste nous n'avons
absolument pas la même vision que nos
collègues de l'opposition sur le
résultat auquel nous sommes arrivés
certes il y a matière encore à débattre
et sans doute à améliorer ce texte nous
ne pouvons que regretter que la
procédure accélérée n'est pas donnée du
temps au temps n'est pas permis
d'avancer dans une discussion plus
plus froide plus paisible sur un sujet
aussi important je voudrais souligner
d'ailleurs que ce sujet
si les opinions ici se confrontent c'est
tout de même un sujet qui est inscrit
dans je dirais l'histoire du Sénat et
que beaucoup de ces questions de qui
concerne la dignité des personnes en
milieu pénitentiaire les questions qui
concernent
l'ensemble de la chaîne pénale la
protection des libertés individuelles
font partie de d'un champ de travail
constant ici au Sénat et donc il est
normal que nous ayons suivi avec une
certaine passion l'élaboration de ce
texte et je le répète nous regrettons
tous que la procédure accélérée nous est
mis devant des sortes de d'ultimatum
ceci étant au terme du débat nous ne
portons pas du tout le regard sévère qui
est formulé ici
par l'opposition et hors de nos murs y
compris je crois qu'il faut le dire dans
l'autre chambre du Parlement à
l'Assemblée nationale le regard sévère
qui est porté sur le résultat auquel
nous arrivons au Sénat le travail du
Sénat a à notre sens
conforter le projet initial de lutte
contre la récidive et
de donner du sens à la sanction pénale
un sens qui est souvent perdu de vue du
fait même des difficultés en particulier
de notre système pénitentiaire mais
aussi tout simplement des difficultés de
notre justice dont on sait qu'elle est
loin d'avoir des moyens à la hauteur de
ses missions et nous apprécions ici
madame la ministre le travail que vous
avez accompli depuis votre arrivée place
Vendôme pour petit à petit
raisonnablement mais de façon très
déterminée améliorer les conditions de
travail de l'ensemble des acteurs de la
justice nous vous en sommes
reconnaissants donc le texte auquel nous
sommes arrivés qui soulève un certain
nombre de craintes et d'interrogations
que vous avez d'ailleurs fort bien
exprimé madame la ministre en tout cas
de la part du gouvernement et je le
répète aussi de la part de l'autre
assemblée est un texte qui contrairement
parce que nous entendons est loin d'être
déraisonnable peut-être est-il un peu en
avant un peu trop en avant sur la
situation actuelle de l'opinion sur la
manière dont les différentes forces
politiques veulent se positionner par
rapport à l'opinion s'il est parfois un
peu en avance c'est parce que nous avons
une
réelle préoccupation de la situation à
laquelle nous sommes confrontés sur
cette question de la délinquance et de
la prévention de la récidive parce que
mes chers collègues et je terminerai par
là nous aurions pu adopter une solution
une
une posture comme il a été dit souvent
de statu quo d'extrême prudence de ne
pas poser les problèmes qui à nos yeux
sont des vrais problèmes mais ce faisant
nous nous trouvions
toujours face à un mur le mur auquel
toutes les majorités sont confrontées et
seront confrontés demain si on n'arrive
pas à faire bouger la situation actuelle
c'est une situation où à la fois la
délinquance et bien elle est présente
dans notre société ni plus ni moins
d'ailleurs que dans les décennies
passées mais elle est là elle inquiète
beaucoup et surtout elle met en danger
les nouvelles générations donc si nous
ne nous donnions pas au Parlement le
moyen de d'un certain nombre d'avancées
sur la loi pénale nous manquerions je
crois à notre devoir à l'égard des
nouvelles générations ce sont elles qui
ont le plus à souffrir de la situation
actuelle de notre justice de notre
système pénitentiaire
si nous n'avons pas le courage de faire
bouger un certain nombre de choses et de
ce point de vue l'introduction de la
contrainte pénale est à l'évidence une
avancée courageuse que nous vous devons
aussi madame la ministre et que je tiens
à saluer là si nous ne faisons pas ces
avancées nous resterons devant un mur et
un mur sur laquelle sur lequel nous
allons tous de plus en plus nous casser
la tête donc je pense que nous avons
travaillé à la commission des lois et
dans le groupe socialiste pour faire
avancer les choses le texte issu de
l'Assemblée nationale n'est pas
au-dessus de toute critique et
d'ailleurs un certain nombre
d'amendements qui ont été adoptés
prouvent qu'il y avait du chemin à faire
reste entre nous des désaccords entre
les différentes composantes de notre
assemblée avec l'Assemblée nationale
avec le gouvernement reste des points de
désaccord je veux redire ce que j'ai
déjà dit à nous d'utiliser au mieux le
temps qui qui reste devant nous jusqu'à
la commission mixte paritaire pour nous
entendre sur un certain nombre de points
sans nous arrêter à une position de
négation d'un certain nombre d'évidences
et de problèmes qu'il fallait bien
mettre sur la table à ce point en tout
cas madame la ministre le groupe
socialiste votre a le texte tel qu'il
est issu de nos travaux je vous remercie
madame taska la parole est à Monsieur le
cerf
oui madame la présidente Madame le
Ministre chers collègues sur deux points
je rejoins l'opinion qui vient d'être
présenté par notre collègue madame taska
sur la spécificité du Sénat notamment
sur les problèmes de liberté j'ai
souvent dit qu'il y avait effectivement
deux catégories de problèmes sur le sur
lequel le Sénat jouait un rôle très
particulier le problème bien sûr de la
défense des collectivités territoriales
et nous attendrons quelques jours de
plus et j'ai bien compris pour pouvoir
nous pencher sur ce dossier et le
problème de la défense des libertés et
cela depuis très longtemps je que ce
soit d'ailleurs collectivement ou que ce
soit par l'intermédiaire de ces
exécutifs je pense par exemple la
saisine par le président power en son
temps du Conseil constitutionnel sur les
problèmes de liberté d'association je
regrette également le fait que la
procédure d'urgence a été utilisée je
pense que sur des questions de cette
nature qui marque de manière très
profonde la politique pénale ce n'est
pas un bon choix que d'utiliser la
procédure d'urgence je n'en tiens pas
rigueur au gouvernement je sais combien
le précédent gouvernement avait commis
sur ce point les mêmes erreurs et j'ai
peur que ce qui est vrai lorsque l'on
est dans l'opposition devienne
effectivement contre vérité lorsque l'on
passe dans la majorité hélas
sur la qualité des débats qui a nous ont
réuni ces quelques jours
ayant pris la peine de lire globalement
les débats de l'Assemblée nationale je
pense pas que Senna est à rougir des
débats qui nous ont réunis car si nous
n'avons pas effectivement les mêmes
opinions si sur bien des articles nous
nous sommes opposés nous sommes toujours
écoutés avec respect des opinions des
uns et des autres et parfois même nous
avons réussi à nous entendre donc je
pense que sur ce point nous avons fait
progresser les le texte qui nous avait
été présentés en ce qui concerne le
groupe UMP le groupe UMP dans son
immense majorité puisque c'est tous sauf
un si je peux m'exprimer ainsi votre a
contre ce projet de loi pour des raisons
qui ont été exprimées avec beaucoup de
clarté notamment par notre collègue
Jean-Jacques yes que ce soit lors de la
discussion générale ou que ce soit lors
des amendements qu'il a déposé et qu'il
a déf
avec la crainte effectivement que ce
projet de loi donne un signe de
d'indulgence un vis-à-vis effectivement
des délinquants ou apprentis délinquant
signe d'indulgence qui a aujourd'hui ne
paraît pas être effectivement de
circonstances
eu égards et au regard des problèmes
effectivement délinquance que nous
connaissions en ce qui me concerne
pardonnez-moi de parler de moi en ce qui
me concerne je ne voterai pas contre ce
projet de loi pour plusieurs raisons les
deux raisons principales c'est que la
contrainte pénale qui doit beaucoup à
Pierre Victor Tournier dont je pense que
le nom pouvait être au moins une fois
prononcé effectivement ici la contrainte
pénale mérite très largement d'être
approfondie c'est une idée qui est une
idée tout à fait intéressante c'est
l'une des idées qui nous permettrait
peut-être sur le chemin difficile de la
lutte contre la récidive d'obtenir
effectivement des résultats qui soit des
résultats plus performants plus
efficaces plus visibles que ce que nous
avons accepté avec bonne foi les uns et
des autres depuis un certain nombre
d'années et d'autre part je ne peux pas
ne pas être attentif au fait que sur un
certain nombre de points importants
cette réforme n'a pas dévoué la loi
pénitentiaire mais au contraire à tenter
d'en revenir sinon à la lettre du moins
à l'esprit
je ne voterai pas non plus cette réforme
je ne voterai pas contre je ne voterai
pas pour donc je ne m'abstiendrai parce
que j'estime que nous avons été tenté ou
la majorité a été tentée de mélanger à
ce texte un certain nombre d'autres
problèmes qui pour moi n'avait pas
totalement leur place dans ce débat
qu'il s'agisse du problème effectivement
de la rétention de sûreté sur lequel la
réponse finale est une réponse qui me
convenait ou qu'il s'agisse du problème
des tribunaux correctionnels pour
mineurs j'en veux une seule preuve c'est
le titre de actuel de ce projet de loi
projet de loi pour renforcer
l'efficacité des sanctions pénales alors
que l'on pense ce que l'on veut des
tribunaux correctionnels pour mineurs je
ne pense pas et je suis même convaincu
que leur disparition ne contribuera en
rien à renforcer l'efficacité des
sanctions pénales
merci Monsieur Le Cerf madame cuerman
vous avez la parole
oui madame la présidente madame Miss mes
chers collègues quelques mots tout
d'abord
quelques regrets effectivement comme
l'ont exprimé mes collègues sur
l'utilisation de la procédure accélérée
parce que je crois à travers les débats
que nous avons eu sur ces sur ces trois
jours que l'on voit bien sur certains
points que cela aurait mérité des
approfondissements et malheureusement le
fonctionnement de la CMP est telle que
cela risque plus d'être des compromis
que des approfondissements un autre
regret également sur le temps de ce
débat parlementaire qui est l'éruption
plus ou moins directe du président de la
République dans dans les débats
parlementaires puisque au lendemain des
travaux de la commission des lois de
l'Assemblée nationale le Président de la
République c'est en quelque sorte permis
de rappeler à l'ordre pour maintenir
l'équilibre du texte tel qu'il était à
son entrée à l'Assemblée nationale je le
regrette je crois que le partage des
pouvoir est une chose
largement
vanter et développer plutôt pardon
excusez-moi par Montesquieu et je crois
que c'est en tout cas ceux qui doivent
faire le fondement de notre République
et le temps de ce travail parlementaire
dans le temps de la lecture à
l'Assemblée nationale puis au Sénat doit
être respecté
pour maintenir cette république
parlementaire enfin sur les points
positifs de votre texte madame la
ministre je crois qu'il s'agissait il
s'agit d'un texte ambitieux d'un texte
ambitieux parce que ils vise finalement
à interroger sur l'efficacité et
l'utilité d'une peine quelle qu'elle
soit
ou qu'elle se déroule en milieu fermé ou
en milieu ouvert et elle vise aussi plus
largement à nous interroger sur le
parcours de la peine et le travail qui
doit être fait avec la personne
condamnée et ce finalement cette
réflexion nous aurons à la voir quelle
que soit la durée de la peine sur lui
permettre la sortie sa réinsertion par
la suite elle vise aussi à éviter la
récidive et je crois que c'est quelque
chose d'important de fondamental en
introduisant la contrainte pénale pour
ces petits délits du quotidien ces
petits délits du quotidien qui certes
par peut aussi gêner déranger mais
vraiment j'ai insiste qui ne sont que
les petits délits du quotidien
auxquels à nos collègues le rappelait en
début d'après-midi finalement chacune et
chacun d'entre nous connaît qui peut un
jour y être confronté comment l'on
interroge finalement plus la personne
sur les pourquoi de son de son acte
comment
et pourquoi c'est cet acte est interdit
comment finalement se faire pardonner
aux yeux de la société plutôt quand le
mettant simplement en prison en faire
très certainement un récidiviste qui
d'ailleurs progressivement pour y
glisser du délit au crime dans la
récidive donc je crois que c'est un
texte et pour cela qui est ambitieux qui
marque effectivement une volonté
d'apporter des réponses à notre société
plutôt que d'écarter les mots je l'ai
également déjà dit un texte aussi qui
nous invite à poursuivre à poursuivre
l'évolution nécessaire de notre justice
en ce début de 21ème siècle justice qui
doit toujours être au service des
citoyens et de la société dans laquelle
ces citoyens vivent et non
malheureusement comme nous avons pu
parfois trop souvent le voir dans ces
dernières décennies le bras armé d'une
majorité politique en place en ce sens
madame la garde des sceaux nous voterons
ce texte je vous remercie madame
la parole est à Monsieur kuanella
la présidente Paname des ministres mes
chers collègues il détrègne à donner
tout à l'heure très clairement la
position du groupe je voudrais
simplement ajouter rapidement 5
commentaires
le premier concerne la prison la notion
de privation de la liberté
je crois qu'il est clair que la prison
ne règle pas la question de la récidive
on a démontré ici avec talent parfois
que malheureusement elle l'aggrave
pour autant la prison reste un mal
nécessaire et quelque part la société
n'a pas trouvé mieux que la privation de
la liberté face à un certain nombre de
délits graves pour manifester la
réprobation de la société et pour
sanctionner
deuxième commentaire
penser que la contrainte pénale réglera
la contrainte réglera pardon la question
de la récitive ça me paraît ça restait
une pétition de principe on sait que la
prison quelque part la grave mais estimé
que la contrainte pénale réglera la
récifs je pense que c'est une idée qu'il
faut considérer avec beaucoup de
prudence troisièmement dans les débats
face à l'accusation de permissivité
disons j'ai entendu notamment hier soir
certaines tendances à dire mais
finalement au contraire de ce qu'on
pourrait penser la contrainte pénale
sera plus effective que des mesures qui
ne sont pas exécutées aujourd'hui
là aussi je crois que c'est tactiquement
compréhensible mais
ça reste quand même une idée qu'il
faudra
reconsidérer dans les faits je le dis
avec un peu de malice ça n'était sans
doute pas l'intention initiale en tout
cas d'être plus dur avec la contrainte
pénale qui avait les mécanismes actuels
notamment celui de la prison mais ça
m'amène un quatrième point il me semble
que la question de fond dans nos débats
c'est que la contrainte pénale n'est pas
suffisamment définie dans ce texte et
étant mal défini elle peut se révéler ou
trop faible
ou peut-être suivons comment les mises
en œuvre trop forte et que cette absence
de définition claire a posé
véritablement question et qu'elle est
troublante dernier point enfin je pense
que paradoxalement la contrainte pénale
à la suite de la loi pénitentielle est
vécue comme une mesure alternative à la
prison et sans doute une idée qui peut
prospérer mais dans un cadre autre que
celui qui a fixé ce texte je pense qu'il
aurait fallu l'installer dans le débat
public et dans la loi avec une sérénité
plus grande et comme une alternative à
la prison clairement mais de manière
progressive évaluée et pragmatique et
qu'ici malheureusement la condition n'a
pas été remplie au contraire j'en
termine en remercions bien évidemment
prison de la commission des doigts notre
rapporteur évidemment au premier chef et
madame la ministre qui ont permis cet
échange qu'il faudra je pense poursuivre
je vous remercie si chers collègues
dernière intervenante inscrite madame
Benbassa
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur chers collègues
et comme je l'ai déjà dit dans ma DG les
écologistes approuvent ce texte et il
voteront les travaux de la commission et
ceux qui ont été fait en séance
ont abouti à un texte qui va peut-être
changer l'esprit de la justice bien sûr
si la contrainte pénale devient une
peine à part entière et qu'elle est
expliquée correctement au public la
pédagogie sur le rôle de cette peine
pour lutter contre la récidive reste à
faire et il est urgent de la faire
puisque on lit déjà dans la presse des
textes qui crient au laxisme et ils sont
pas les premiers de même sur le fait que
la prison n'est pas une solution pour
les petits délits et qu'il y a d'autres
moyens de réhabilitation des petits
délinquant nous sommes satisfaits
également que les tribunaux pour mineurs
étaient supprimés certes il reste encore
beaucoup pas faire de même cette réforme
n'annulement oublié les victimes mais
les protège davantage ce texte ne relève
pas seulement du réforme pénale mais
aussi sociétale qui souhaitent resserrer
le lien social et mettre fin à la
binarité
coupable victime nous sommes fiers de ce
texte vraiment de gauche tel qu'il est
sorti de la Commission et de la séance
il y aura toujours des reproches des
critiques c'est inévitable nous avions
besoin d'un peu d'audace
et
cette réforme pénale mais du baume au
coeur et qui pourra dire désormais que
cosena nous manquons d'ambition et de
liberté merci
madame Benbassa monsieur le Président
sur vous avez la parole
la présidente et Madame la Ministre et
mes chers collègues Jaurès scrupule de
prolonger à cette heure-ci mais je
voulais simplement
suite à ce qui a été dit par Madame
taska particulièrement par Monsieur Le
Cerf que donc je tiens à saluer le
discours puisque finalement
il a été le seul à avoir une position
différente et la
néanmoins dû avec abnégation exposée la
position de tous les autres
je tiens à saluer tout ce qui a été dit
mais vous avez dit à juste titre qu'il
était regrettable qu'il y a eu une
procédure accélérée
mais je me permets de tempérer un peu
cela mais je partage complètement parce
que je dois dire aussi que nous avons
assisté et participer
en raison de votre engagement madame la
ministre a une préparation de ce texte
qui a été quelque chose d'exceptionnel
et même sans précédent puisque il y a eu
d'abord la préparation de la conférence
de consensus avec une trentaine de
personnes très différentes qui ont
travaillé et cette conférence restera un
moment dans l'histoire
ou 2000 personnes
toutes les professions de la Justice ont
été appelés à travailler dans un climat
remarquable si l'on prend la conférence
de consensus puis la conférence qui a
lieu à l'Unesco on a
d'innombrables témoignages du fait qu'il
y a eu un véritable mouvement et ce
mouvement il a permis d'élaborer un
texte qui est un texte extrêmement
novateur
parce qu'on sort des idées toutes faites
selon laquelle il n'y aurait qu'une
référence à la prison pour les peines on
en a assez parlé mais une vision
équilibrée dans laquelle puisque nous
sommes contre l'impunité nous sommes
pour la diversité des peines et nous
voulons que la contrainte pénale prenne
toute sa place
alors vous avez madame ku Kerman parlait
de la commission mixte paritaire et vous
avez dit que vous souhaitez que vous
souhaitiez que ce soit un
approfondissement plutôt qu'un compromis
moi je partage ce feu
nous avons et je tiens à saluer madame
la ministre et monsieur le rapporteur
qui a veillé avec beaucoup de vigilance
à ce que l'on respecte
l'esprit de cette loi l'esprit du projet
de loi
et cela nous a valu je dois le dire un
certain nombre de critiques de remarques
alors que nous sommes très attachés à
l'esprit de ce texte et un certain
nombre de principes fondamentaux du
droit et de la justice
nous y tenons et c'est vrai que nous
espérons de tout cœur arrivé à un accord
avec nos collègues députés sur la base
d'un approfondissement du travail
effectué dans les deux assemblées nous
l'espérons parce que nous pensons qu'il
est très nécessaire que cette loi
s'applique maintenant rapidement on en a
assez parlé il faut maintenant qu'elle
s'applique dans l'intérêt des
justiciables des personnes qui sont
dans les prisons ou qui sont qui qui
vivront ces situations dans la
contrainte pénale dans leur intérêt et
dans l'intérêt de la société je crois
que c'est un grand signe d'espoir quand
elle texte puisse être voté et j'espère
de tout cœur que nous arriverons à
garder l'état d'esprit qui est le nôtre
tout en arrivant un accord avec nos
collègues députés en tout cas je peux
vous dire que c'est
que nous ferons tout ce qui en notre
pouvoir pour y parvenir en respectant
l'esprit qui a présidé à ce débat je
vous remercie tous
je mets d'abord au revoir madame la
ministre voilà merci Monsieur le
présidentiel je mets au voir l'ensemble
du projet de loi dans la Commission a
ainsi rédiger l'intitulé projet de loi
relatif un individualisation des peines
et à la prévention de la récidive donc
qui vote le texte qui est pour
merci qui est contre
merci qui s'abstient je vous remercie le
texte est donc adapté
madame la ministre vous avez la parole
oui merci madame la Présidente je n'ai
pas abusé de votre patience monsieur le
président de la commission des lois
monsieur le rapporteur mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs je
tiens néanmoins à vous remercier très
très chaleureusement pour la qualité des
échanges pour la qualité des
interventions lors de la discussion
générale y compris pour la motion de
procédure qui était présenté par l'UMP
qui n'était pas qui ne nous a pas mis
devant des points de procédure mais qui
de façon tout à fait intéressante à
soulever des points de contenu et à
exprimer des arguments d'opposition je
veux vous remercier pour la qualité des
échanges pendant la discussion des
articles et la présentation des
amendements vous avez incontestablement
contribué à enrichir ce texte de loi
renforcer ces conditions d'efficacité
vous l'aviez amélioré déjà en commission
des lois vous l'avez encore
amélioré même si je le regret d'une ou
deux dispositions que vous avez voté
vous l'avez encore amélioré mais je
crois que les quelques jours qui nous
séparent de la commission mixte
paritaire on vous conduire sans doute à
vous poser sur
quelques dispositions sur lesquelles
nous avons eu des échanges mais vous
avez
renforcé la colonne vertébrale de ce
texte de loi je vous en remercie
chaleureusement c'est un texte de loi
qui est inspiré par notre souci de
renforcer le contrat social je l'ai dit
je le pense profondément et toute
l'action publique de ce gouvernement
montre cette préoccupation de renforcer
le contrat social c'est-à-dire d'assurer
le devoir de l'État de protection de
l'ensemble des citoyens avec une
attention particulière pour les victimes
et j'ai eu l'opportunité d'exposer la
politique d'aide aux victimes que nous
conduisons depuis deux ans nous avons le
souci aussi de renforcer le pacte
républicain ce pacte de républicain qui
doit consolider les liens qui nous
permettent de vivre ensemble et l'acte
de délinquance brise ce lien il est
important que nous fassions en sorte que
la peine
non seulement punisse mais qu'elle
contribue aussi par son exécution par la
responsabilisation de l'auteur par les
conditions dans lesquelles on le en lui
permet de revenir dans le corps social
dans la société ou d'y rester d'exécuter
sa peine sans rompre avec la société le
corps social que ces conditions-là
soient réunies qu'elle soit améliorées
de façon à ce qu'effectivement nous
puissions consolider le corps social et
vous avez raison monsieur le sénateur le
cerf de rendre hommage aux travailleurs
obstiné qu'a conduit Pierre Victor
Tournier qui tenait une contrainte
pénale dans la communauté et qui est un
des artisans de cette des travaux qui
ont conduit à cette réforme il n'est pas
seul il y a de nombreuses personnes du
milieu parlementaire du milieu
judiciaire du milieu universitaire qui
ont contribué à ça mais un
contestablement Pierre Victor Tournier
occupe une place particulière donc merci
d'avoir contribué à ce que par ce texte
de loi qui de façon lucide a fait un
bilan de la situation et appris à sa
vraie mesure
la détresse que crée dans la société
l'acte de délinquance détresse pour la
victime mais détresse pour une société
elle-même qui s'interroge sur les
risques qui existent dans la société et
qui peuvent s'abattre sur elle merci
d'avoir faire en sorte faire en sorte
que prenant sérieusement lucidement la
mesure de cette réalité la délinquance
ne sont pas des statistiques et même
lorsque les statistiques baissent et
montrent que le nombre d'acte de
délinquance diminue chaque acte de
délinquance lorsqu'il a fait une victime
ou plusieurs victimes est un axe qui
blesse la société donc dans chaque acte
de délinquance il y a au moins une
personne blessée et ça nous devons tenir
compte donc quel que soit le nombre
d'acte de délinquance quel que soit les
taux d'évolution ou de régression il y a
de la souffrance dans les actes de
délinquance donc nous sommes fixés le
défi d'être efficace et de prévenir
réellement la récidive c'est à dire non
pas seulement de lutter contre la
récidive comme la loi sur les peines
plancher avaient affiché comme objectif
de viser à obtenir comme résultat lutter
contre la récidive c'est-à-dire la
sanctionner plus sévèrement nous voulons
en plus de cela prévenir la récidive
c'est-à-dire créer les conditions pour
qu'il n'y ait pas la commission de ces
nouveaux actes de délinquance donc merci
à vous tous de l'avoir fait le
gouvernement a travaillé avec rigueur
pour la préparation de ce texte vous
avez rappelé la conférence de consensus
j'ajoute que dans le Tour de France que
j'ai effectué de façon à présenter ce
texte en exposer le contenu j'ai
rencontré des personnes qui parfois
avaient de très fortes prévention j'ai
rencontré des personnes qui avaient été
très fortement doctriné sur le prétendu
laxisme de ce texte et de nos intentions
j'ai entendu des personnes qui ne
savaient pas du tout de quoi on parlait
j'ai rencontré les personnes toutes les
fois y compris parfois lorsque la
rencontre au début était extrêmement
dure parce que les gens étaient sur des
positions ou sur des postures
extrêmement fermées
toutes les fois où le dialogue a pu
s'établir et il s'est établit à chaque
fois au bout du compte les personnes se
sont posées et ont raisonné et ça permet
de rappeler que ce pays c'est le pays de
la raison que l'histoire de la France
l'histoire de la philosophie des
Lumières l'histoire collective de cette
société c'est l'histoire de
l'émancipation de l'individu par la
raison et c'est ce que nous faisons là
nous avons des textes de loi des
politiques publiques des mesures qui ont
été prises avec le souci dont je ne
doute pas de la sincérité qui consistait
à lutter contre la récidive nous avons
la mesure des résultats de ces
politiques et de ses dispositions il
s'agit pas de porter de jugement de
valeur nous n'avons pas de temps ni
d'énergie à perdre sur ces exercices 20
il ne s'agit pas de porter de jugement
de valeur il s'agit de constater que la
réalité est que nous n'avons pas encore
réussi à
réduire de façon significative la
récidive c'est ce que ce texte prétend
et c'est ce que nous allons faire alors
nous entendons encore parler du laxisme
parce que le laxisme est devenu un
mantra dans ce pays mais je crois la
raison de ce pays je crois justement à
ces constants à ces invariants qui font
que dans ce pays même lorsque
collectivement les gens semblent
complètement égarés il revient un moment
où il se pose et il se soumettent à ce
que j'ai appris après Bertol Brest bien
entendu la douce violence de la raison
donc je ne doute pas que ce mantra
finira par se dissiper parce qu'il n'a
pas d'emprise parce qu'il n'a pas de
consistance et surtout parce qu'il n'a
pas d'illustration qui n'a pas de
démonstration donc je sais que ça va
finir par s'évanouir est-ce que vous
avez fait
pendant ces quelques jours de débat on
améliorant ce texte avec la hauteur et
la qualité des propos que vous avez
tenus tous et que le sérieux avec lequel
ces échanges ont pu avoir lieu a déjà
contribué à faire reculer ce mantra a
déjà contribué à faire en sorte que
comme nous y invitons nous y invitons
time pardon wedgame style nous comme il
nous y invitait à lutter contre
l'ensorcellement de notre temps de mort
par les moyens du langage dommage que
son nom était aussi différent
voilà pour l'adoption de la réforme
pénale c'était hier soir au Sénat vous
l'avez vu l'ensemble des forces de la
gauche ce sont rassemblés pour adopter
ce texte tandis que l'UMP est centriste
ont voté contre à l'exception notable de
Jean-René Lecerf Nater UMP qui lui s'est
abstenu vous l'avez vu le texte a été
profondément modifié par le Sénat
prochaine étape il y a la commission
mixte paritaire qui devrait se réunir le
8 juillet commission mixte paritaire qui
réunit cette députés cette sénateurs qui
vont devoir se mettre d'accord sur une
version commune du texte vous pouvez
toujours voir et revoir toutes les
séances sur notre site sur public
sénat.fr prochain rendez-vous de
l'actualité parlementaire ce soir à 19h
pour 24 heures Sénat présenté par
Delphine Girard très bonne journée sur
les chaînes parlementaires